all right just to take it back to old
school I'm gonna talk about something
so like not important but when's the
last time you paid for a proper
spa treatment like a massage last week
yeah yeah okay how long had it been
since then
um probably like a month I get massages
pretty often oh okay yeah okay it's like
one of the things that I just
it's like a life hack for me it's like
one of the things that I think people
don't get them enough I mean obviously
they're expensive yes but if you can
afford it I think it's absolutely 100
worth it and socialist Tick Tock is
gonna eat you up for that why they're
just gonna be mad at you for spending
money on expensive massages yeah I mean
I I go to like the they're not that
expensive oh do you you just get like
like if you saw a lady in the mall and
she's like I'll rub your back yeah like
the airport ones right just kind of like
lie down on this thing
in public yeah there's a guy that does
it on the boardwalk in Venice I just go
to him he's also a psychic too which is
sick he really like tells my future at
the same time he just brings your feet
up and he's like reading your future but
like rubbing your feet
I see a long path in your future yeah
he's a foot palm reader whoa that's not
my foot
let me relax you okay
reaching under between
pulling it back
damn damn bro
you got the dick and balls both in there
he's like I know how are you even doing
that is it I do this all the time it's
nice
pulling my own feet up to my own balls
how are you is this a stretch am I what
am I getting your jacket
but he's guiding your feet making a foot
position under your feet how are you
this feels awesome
I know
what was he out of your own feet
[Laughter]
and then in the middle of it just
slashed the [ __ ] out of your back
oh all right all done yeah yeah little
body gloves and it yeah I feel
good I think
did I come will that be coming yeah no
but you're out you're out cold you're
out well that's why I get massages
actually I used to fall asleep and I
miss the whole thing yeah but it is the
deepest sleep ever for me it is the
ultimate form of relaxation for me is a
massage a 300 nap it's not 300 bucks no
it's like 75. yeah yeah sorry for an
hour I'm sorry I'm not trying to miss
that is that that's like
I mean it's expensive but it's like not
like you go to like a nice hotel and
yeah you'll pay like 200 bucks for an
hour yeah that to me is expensive yeah
no no I'm not trying to mischaracterize
it I I say 300 for a nap because so I
got two during the wedding nice they
were both at hotels so they're stupid
expensive but I think the funniest part
is
when you pay that much money and they're
trying to nag you into buying products
what yeah so that's the thing is I think
the places you're going
it's understood my man's coming here
yeah to pass out for 45 minutes 100 and
I'm gonna send him to the Grave for 45
minutes yeah they go how long and I'm
like
80 minutes they're like cool you want to
walk on your back I'm like no I don't
like that okay cool
pass out an hour later they'll wake up
because they're like please flip you
flip they do the front side but
sometimes and then you tip them on
venmone then you're done yeah sometimes
if you're lucky you'll just you don't
need you don't even remember the flip
yeah but you'll just then you're like
wake up and you're already yeah how did
you do that yeah it brought more other
yeah turn you around
damn I just gotta flashback to that
weird ass New York apartment massage we
got
what it was on tour and you're like you
wanna go get a massage I was like yeah
oh yeah we went up to that place and we
were like this seems cool and then we
went inside and we're like wait this is
kind of like a house oh my God we went
up the narrow ass elevator yeah oh my
God and then it was like basically an
apartment yeah and it was just a bunch
of old Thai ladies yeah that was uh that
was the day after one of the worst panic
attacks in my entire life which I can
tell you about after but sorry keep
going with the anyways yeah so whatever
uh
yeah so the Italian massage
both times you know I'm paying I'm
paying
like 200 bucks 250 bucks I'm you know
I'm like [ __ ] it vacation ball out
and both times
at the end they're just trying to nag me
to buy more products
like talking [ __ ] about my skin ah like
uh at the Four Seasons one the girl goes
your back has a lot of imperfections
[ __ ] does that mean
so crazy to just make you so relaxed
when you wake up and it's like your skin
looks horrible
yo you're [ __ ] up yeah the way would
you like a pink bath salt to scrub all
that [ __ ] off your back you're aging
poorly yeah yeah
there's a 600 face cream yeah that we
think would work really well for you you
don't use sunscreen right yeah you can
tell you're like I do use sunscreen yeah
I I just I couldn't believe it you know
the first time I got nagged is a
different Hotel I'm thinking okay
you know maybe
maybe it's just here
the second time they neg me I'm like
dude
you're you're wrapping up you're like
tipping them and then they go oh by the
way like they want pedal use some cream
that they have there yeah it's like
they're on commission
that's stupid yeah that's that's really
annoying yeah it's so not relaxing yeah
not at all but Elena and I left and
we're just laughing like that was so
cool
we paid 200 to fall asleep to wake up
for someone to be like hey someone to
give us like try to sell us a time share
you're getting old
hahaha yeah
hey your your skin is looking really bad
I give massages to a lot of people yeah
he's one of the worst for me yeah
because your skin is so disgusting
also that lady
she was like rubbing my foot which
normally doesn't happen to me in most
massages I've not had my foot rubbed
yeah I guess it was part of her style
okay she just grabs one of my toes and
it's just kind of
I'm like don't do that
not the grippers yeah yeah it was just
crossing into a territory hey yeah
get off my [ __ ] grippers
she's like sorry yeah they grabbed me
first
yeah I'm like oh look I look back it's
like wrapped around her fingers yeah my
bad they'll do that they got a mind of
Their Own
those boys do what they want
she
she went down to your mic your feet are
massaging her hand yeah yeah
I simply just reached down they just
grabbed me
really good yeah
she's she's asleep laughs
ah damn it happened again
my damn grippers my grippers they just
know no limits anyways yeah
yeah I had a I got negged twice and
actually I paid for a facial before the
wedding like make my skin better that is
a little bit different that's never done
one of those you should yeah does it
help
help does it make you look better yeah
like it definitely makes your skin look
better and like they just couldn't give
you advice about your skin
um depending who you go sometimes
they're cool they're like you can buy
this [ __ ] here but you don't have to
others they're like car salesmen yeah
you know yeah slap your face oh yeah
this but this baby right here
it's it's at least got you know 10 more
degrees SPF it could it could go